Speaker 1: For years now.
One of the false claims that the right has
been throwing at the left in the United States
is that the left wants to defund the police.
Now, we've covered this so extensively.
Certainly you can go on Twitter or Reddit
and find some people who say defund the police
or all cops are bastards or whatever slogan
they come up with.
But overwhelmingly, no one wants to defund
the police.
Even those in the Democratic Party, the vast
majority, say we need to reform the police.
I've put out a pretty extensive 8 to 10 point
plan on how to improve policing, and this
includes training and retraining of different
kinds.
This includes demilitarization.
This includes, yes, having a an unarmed force
that can respond to certain types of calls,
but in some cases, it actually might involve
funding the police more in order to get police
away from the low hanging fruit policing that
actually causes the problems anyway.
The point is, you know as well as I do, I'm
sure that defund the police exists almost
nowhere and has no influence on the mainstream
Democratic Party.
And suddenly Republican Congressman Jim Jordan
says he's going to defund the police because
Trump was indicted.
Now he's talking, of course, of federal police.
And it's become very popular for Republicans
to go after federal police.
Let's take a look at this clip.
This is from the Maria BARTIROMO program over
the weekend.
Take a listen.
It is nation.
Speaker 2: Right laws and pass legislation.
So we'll look at that.
And maybe most importantly, Maria, is we control
the power of the purse and that's what we're
going to.
Speaker 1: Have to look at the appropriations
process and.
Speaker 2: Limit funds going to some of these
agencies, particularly the ones who are engaged
in the most egregious behavior.
So the DOJ and the FBI.
Yeah.
And what I'd really like, frankly.
Speaker 1: Yeah, the DOJ and the FBI.
They want to defund federal police.
They say we are for law and order and against
defunding the police.
But all of a sudden, Donald Trump has to comply
with the law and the legal orders as they
love to obsess with of law enforcement and
prosecutors and so on and so forth.
And all of a sudden they say, get rid of the
entire department, defund the FBI, defund
the DOJ.
These are the very same people who while saying,
we support the police and you're bad for wanting
to defund the police were on the side of the
rioters rather than the police when it came
to the January 6th riotous insurrection.
And in this particular case with Trump and
we still listen, it's going to be a while
until we know the full scope of what the repercussions
are going to be.
We don't know if Trump will be indicted in
Georgia.
We don't know if the Mar a Lago search warrant
is going to lead to an indictment that this
first arrest and indictment may only be the
tip of the iceberg, for lack of a better term,
we don't know.
But all of a sudden we have someone being
potentially held accountable overwhelmingly
for things that are on tapes of different
kinds.
I mean, Trump called Georgia and said, I need
11,000 votes.
Give me a break.
It's we have a recording and there may be
crimes there.
And all of a sudden they don't want accountability.
They claim to be the party of personal responsibility,
and yet they want to blame everyone other
than the alleged criminal himself for what
is taking place.
And at its core, one of the aspects of this
that we have to consider is they really seemed
not to believe they might lose back in 2020
when in summer of 2020, Trump started with
the Biden has no crowds at his rallies and
he's in the basement and whatever else, all
of that stuff.
When all of that was going on back in 2020
and Trump started with that, they're going
to try to take it.
They're going to take this, they're going
to steal that.
The other thing they never thought they might
just lose.
They didn't really have a plan for what to
do if they lost other than to lie and claim
they won.
And that devolved into so many other things.
That's separate from the Stormy Daniels indictment
that we're dealing with today.
And so their principles mean nothing.
And they are the ones I mean, listen, have
national Democrats called for a defunding
of law enforcement the way that Jim Jordan
does in this video?
If they have, I certainly haven't seen any
of those examples.
So they are hypocrites.
Hypocrisy knows no bounds.
Republicans don't care about hypocrisy anymore.
But we still have to deal with it on our end
now that they want to do away with the very
law enforcement agencies that are trying,
they may not succeed, but at least they're
trying to hold Trump and some of his cronies
accountable.